we can get started great thanks happy to
have so many people here and we'll talk
with
on the bold question of whether we can
automate supervised machine learning
specifically we talked about this tiny
step important step of tuning the hyper
parameters of the models automatically
so to present myself a little bit I'm
Torben Jensen I'm working for this
company and from our tools for big wheel
of data we're based in the beautiful
city of Muenster and we're happy to
support a larger number of clients to
scale up data science and bring it into
production so this is sort of our
passion and our mission and yes and
while we do this we notice several
things one of them is finding the
optimal hyperplane our models is
important and this being said you might
ask yourself some of you might ask
themselves what is they have a parameter
though let's ask Wikipedia it is happy
parameters are parameters whose values
are set before the learning process
begins by contrast the values of other
parameters are derived by a training one
example would be the depth of your
neural net you don't train that during
the training process you said this
before a hyper parameter and there's
many others just one example and before
we dive into algorithms for
automatically tuning these I want to
take one step back and talk about where
we are located in the soup type line we
could call the pipeline of supervised
machine learning you start with an idea
and data you visualize it at a
preprocessor build your features and
then your tuning and selecting your
models this is what we are going to talk
about this special boxes we're going to
talk about today afterwards we want to
stack your best models deploy them and
monitor them when they're life so these
other steps we focus on the central box
and also to frame the problem that we
want to tackle to make this clear to you
I prepared a week in the life of a data
scientist for you so let's let's look at
this example so you start your week
tuning your model and to be honest it's
fun to explore how the hyper parameters
change the behavior of our models
it's a good thing to do at some point
when you think you're done someone tells
you our well then now there's much more
data and please also use this data for
your model for you that means you have
to go on retune in your model you know
weeks
Thursday's approaching Friday is
approaching when you think you're just
done someone tells you oh yeah this one
variable that you think
everything depends on please remove that
and now you have to go on retuning your
model and maybe it's the weekend already
so that's the problem that we're
tackling understanding hyper parameters
is cool but well maybe we want to want
some weekends off too all right so for
tackling these problems the first steps
I think many of you are familiar with
are grid search and random search grids
are simple but I'll I'll iterate a bit
how it works to make a point
grid search you second select the values
they don't want to test for specific
hyper parameters and try out all the
combinations it's an example here in a
two dimensional space this would look
like this parameter one parameter two
three values each nine combinations look
like looks like a chessboard this looks
fair and efficient actually is not so
efficient because one of the reasons is
that hyper parameters in their effect on
model performance they do vary this is
visualized here on the Left parameter -
in yellow it's not so important for your
model performance well however you set
this parameter is not so important
parameter one however see this peak over
there the green one this is where
parameter one would boost model
performance this is the crucial point
that you would like to find problems
with grid search you're not testing each
parameter at many variations you end up
only testing three variations this is
where you miss and this is example you
missed the you missed the this peak and
this is quite likely to happen in grid
search to the rescue comes random search
in random search well you won't have to
sample more often you just sample
randomly over
over an interval for each hyper
parameter same example here our same
situation you sample nine times but now
your coverage of this important
parameter parameter one is much higher
they actually get the peak right here so
that's great now we see this is this is
one of the reasons why random search
solves for for not just for this
examples for many other examples more
efficient and finding good hyper
parameter combinations automatically
compared to grid search some of you
might have read about this already now
actually we could now stop this talk and
say ok we have a tool that helps us yeah
let's just discuss this in the end sorry
thanks I think there's one limitation
left here that that should be tackled
we're choosing the hyper parameters and
at this part after 9 samples are we got
we got a nice understanding already of
how this power model might react to our
hyper parameter setting but random
search would now just randomly select
new hyper parameters for us to test and
we go on testing randomly I think it's
quite a waste of information because we
already have some information we want to
use this information if we want to use
the information from the previously
tested hyper parameters now there's many
many options and I'd like to talk about
one one option one class of options that
is not just promising and popular but
also like personally quite a lot and
this is the family of sequential model
model based optimization of a type of
Optima have a parameter optimization
that uses all the previously tested
hyper parameters to propose new hyper
parameters it's not a model free
optimization no random search could be
could be you could call the model free
you don't you just test randomly and
then in this you optimize randomly in
this case you use a model for
optimization you already have your
machine machine learning model now you
use another
that will predict from a given
architecture one hidden layer you get a
certain model performance more hidden
layers you get another model performance
you could get this from your original
machine learning model too but that's
slow you take another one
smaller proxy model that predicts
predicts the model performance from the
hyper parameters and for this class of
these algorithms also labelled Bayesian
optimization but we don't need the base
right now so let's cut it out from the
talk they use this fast regression model
as a proxy for your slow machine
learning model the more let's take take
out the same step style presenting now
so first you start by evaluating you
could start by evaluating set of hyper
parameters what we did before we had
nine samples ok gets us started we have
first data from these first from this
first information you build your fast
faster smaller regression model this
proxy model for predicting model
performance from your hyper parameter
now we have this model trained because
it's fast and you can quickly probe this
model for suggesting good hyper
parameters to test next test the models
if it's close from solution will give
you instantly otherwise you'd have to
search within the model and it will tell
you for your original machine learning
model test this parameter because I
think it will be very very good and this
is what you can do next then you
evaluate your original model with a
proposed hyper parameter this is slower
but it gives you real life inside gives
you more information now you have
another say another sampling point now
the hyper parameter tested you can
update your faster regression model your
proxy model and this is sort of a
conversation between these two models
one proposes good hyper parameters next
one tested and so you don't have to run
your slow machine learning model your
original model with it's just maybe not
so promising parameters if they're if
they just be random
now mainly talk about three popular
options for building these fast proxy
models
that's the Gaussian process random
forests and tree structure pars in
estimator let's start with a Gaussian
process let's take an example a
maximization problem where there's a
true relationship between a hyper
parameter that you vary and the model
performance shown there in this dashed
line over there you have to point sample
these are the black dots for two points
you've assembled your hyper parameters
and know sort of the truth how your
model performs at these settings now you
fit the Gershon process to these two
points you get a mean expected value
that's the solid line and you get an
uncertainty range the blue range what
you want to get next if you if you're
maximizing you're looking for a
relatively high expected value but also
high uncertainty so there's still some
room for improvement left this is where
you sample this intuition of combining
this I think is the expected value and
uncertainty is formalizing the
acquisition function here visualized you
would sample at this red triangle this
is what you do you get more information
you find out oh for this type of murder
even though promising we're not optimal
yet but at least you get more
information and you could you get the
next recommendation we're just simple
next so this is how it works sort of in
a nutshell and let now let's look at the
Gaussian process doing exactly this in a
nutshell on the right you have a true
target function and on the Left sorry
there's there's actually the sources or
you have to say this is their sources
from nice blog posts linked in these
pages but the Bema doesn't show them
you'll find them online later there on
the right right hand side so I'm
stealing a lot of brilliant blog post
but I'm linking to them so you can dig
deeper
sorry just just remember all right all
right right hand side you have the
target function two dimensional high
parameter space on the left you have
based on these five initial sampling
points you have the gaussian process we
constructing this this original function
and we see see it in action adding
sampling points and we see first thing
we see we see this reconstructed
Gaussian process sort of converging
towards this this original target
function also samples more in this area
which is a good trade-off between
exploration and exploitation looking for
an optimum here you're maximizing in
this example so you're sampling more
there it's quite efficient so that's the
Gaussian process let's look at the
random force next the random force
actually does very much the same thing
so I'll be so be a bit shorter here two
main differences still are you don't use
the Gaussian process regression use a
decision tree ensemble and ten trees or
it enough to do this to do this one
major advantage here of the random
forest is then you can in your in your
model that predicts from your hyper
parameters model performance you can now
integrate category be scaled parameters
for example the activation function of a
neural net if you want to combine this
if you model the interaction between
that and the learning rate and not
separately might be look might want to
look at the random forests there so well
the rest is more or less the same
finally how does the tree structure
person estimator work again a simplified
example so from an initial set of hyper
parameters that you test and the model
performance in this example we're
minimizing we have a lost I we want to
minimize we're separating between the
best ones the best 20% in this example
and the rest so we create two classes
the red ones and the blue ones we want
to find new hyper parameters that and it
will end up in the red group so for
suggesting good habit parameters that
will end up in this group we model the
probability with a person estimated we
bought model the probability to four new
hyper parameters to end up in the red
group this curve and the blue one the
these vertical ions will be random
suggestions of what next hyper parameter
whose sample and now would these random
suggestions we like to would like to
score or see how much expected
improvement we get from these and for
that we simply divide the probability to
be in the red by the probability to be
in the blue so expected improvement and
we find that this one here it's quite
promising quite likely to be in the red
group so this is how it works
it actually does this separately for
each hyper parameter alright
so much about the algorithms and before
we score them before we show our
benchmarking study I first like to
compare them more on the conceptual
level based on what we know so far so
you might have some criterion some
things that would be useful for us when
we when we use them so maybe you want to
make sure that our optimization
algorithm takes care or also we have
pays attention to the interaction
between hyper parameters if we just
change this one hyper parameter set it
to the other one maybe is not so
efficient we want to take care of the
interaction and actually the tree
structure tree structure person
estimator does not do this well you also
want to include discrete hyper
parameters and the Gaussian process has
some limitations there next criterion
might be you want to have it easily
configured because the worst thing you
need for tuning hyper parameters is an
optimizer that has some hyper
programmers again that you need to chill
how do you how do you do that right
problem is the Gaussian process has some
problems there again because you can you
can really break it and we did that just
configuring this one parameter or not so
ideally and didn't help us a lot
random force is okay you know random
force quite stable and the tree
structure person estimator very easy to
configure
and finally you might want to have a
Python library that you can just import
instant instead of re-implementing
papers from scratch you got it fall of
these huh now you can take your photo or
watch it later happy to help right and
now I think we said for looking up by
other benchmarks are it's just a small
study that will first present and then
we back up with some insight from the
literature because so I guess just one
study would be a bit biased so we're
benchmarking through benchmark set
algorithms with the libraries you see
there also as a baseline we have random
forests sorry
random search as a baseline and we have
a human expert from our team which is I
think very proficient in tuning the type
of model that we're using and that
section X G boost and if you might be
using neural nets we did it with XG
boost decision tree ensemble we used 16
core CPU machines on varying random
seeds etc several weeks of runtime and
two data sets first iris because it's
not a real machine learning study if you
do don't use iris first second we had a
real life data set we wanted to test on
from the insurance world and so few
limitations I think are worth mentioning
first is only two data sets you want to
scale it up to 50 as you studies and use
plenty of data sets so this is with the
better a second one we're talking about
algorithms before now we will commence
marking libraries so we're comparing
actually two things some of these
libraries if you look at their papers
that paying close attention to very
check very may be important technical
optimizations that other libraries might
not do so we're varying two things at
the same time I'm not so ideal for a
benchmarking study but sort of more
real-life
and then look let's look at our first
result on the iris dataset we're
tracking
is the average best result that we're
getting over time from the algorithm so
average means over different random
seeds and our results would look like
this we have all of these algorithms
quickly improving a performance and then
saturating we have sort of a baseline
the the random search sort of sort of
shows us the top here others are better
specifically get the random forest and
respawn estimator did well so this was
over sorry for we'd have to discuss this
later for timing the so this was over
several random seeds now for one random
seed we compared to the human expert
some cures what you're thinking what
you're expecting for this data set sorry
the machine wins and the human only got
this far over three times updating the
hyper parameters oh that's just one
random seed so for a real-life data set
giving giving the same visualization we
see something similar first rapid
improvement and some saturations however
on the same level all of these
algorithms they do differ at the at the
speed and smack shines here I was
wondering why looking better closer at
the logs turns out that that starting
point it's just just lucky it was very
close to the optimum and that's also
well it's okay to be lucky sometimes but
it's so probably helpful for you to know
why even those two smackers is a good
optimizer then again tree pars and
estimators under the top two but well
it's a bit blurred here all right
compared to a human expert now human
expert also got to this level here so
probably the data set may be it may be a
random seed at which it's easier to
an optimum here let's that's real life
right and I'd like to add two studies
from the literature just just to like
quick spotlights from the literature
where something similar has been done
and there's one example where the
Gaussian process was shown to beat
random search so how did this happen in
the beginning that we're not very
different but at some point I think
that's the point in time where the
Gaussian process has enough information
we can start to make good guesses has
understands the hyper parameters space
well enough gets becomes better than the
random search it just goes on randomly
next insight from the literature one
example where a tree structure pardon
estimator beats random the Gaussian
process random search and manual search
in the very end of such a timeline again
over time plotted model performance all
of these the three other ones sort of
end up at this level and in the end
three parts an estimator kicks in and
improves over that so this is a variety
of results here
I'd like to condense a little bit in and
take home messages and welcome to
discussions later
so many people here will have a good
discussion I hope so my personal
take-home messages here is first more
free weekends means it's seems to be
possible to use automated hyper
parameter tuning seems to be better than
manual tuning so more free weekends
these sequential model based
optimization algorithms do not differ
much in performance actually of so
several benchmarking studies and
sometimes this one is better sometimes
the other one we couldn't clearly
distinguish them in our study ourselves
but they come with different constraints
and this might be more important when
you apply them some they have different
capabilities of capture cope with
different scaling of your hyper
parameters think of caution process that
likes
to use continuous hyper parameters
modeling interactions between hyper
parameters can be important and there's
definitely many examples where this is
where that is the case that would be a
problem for the treaty restructure
person estimator and finally as said
some of these algorithms come with a
large number of hyper parameters and
this might have to optimize again at
some point so it's a bit ironic now you
have this machine learning model on top
with hyper parameters uses the Apple
parameter optimization on top with more
hyper parameters so what to do next
that's a philosophical question I have
to leave open for you then we've seen
that the tree structure powers and
estimator is simple but surprisingly
effective it's quite cool
next we've seen the random search being
simple but it's actually quite scalable
and so the reason will be competitive so
not not too bad
finally to sum it up maybe it's my
personal take-home messages to spend my
time wisely and instead of manual tuning
my models I guess on the future I chose
more or I choose more to get more data
and create more features spend my time
there because from the manual tuning and
I'm not expecting so much benefit over
an automated approach alright so these
are my attacker message but before we
can start the discussion yes one more
thing we need to do we have to take this
step back again because we started with
with a question about can we move with
this towards automating supervised
machine learning
thanks for the 1 million dollar question
even more for this central spot central
box we've talked about I'll give a check
mark based on what we've seen so seems
to be possible to automate it to very
high degree what about the other boxes
then let's move a bit downstream there's
this pipeline for stacking models we see
nice ways to automate it'll be very
brief here and we have to talk about all
this probably later stacking models we
see nice nice framework that automate
this first and actually these two
steps together work very nicely in
frameworks think of h2o ml or a large
number of other libraries are available
there when it comes to deployment we
have modern DevOps that help us
automating deployment of these models so
this I think also gets to get to check
mark when it comes to monitoring models
in the wild me personally just
personally I'm not aware of a fa tool
that would capture all my requirements
or fulfill all my requirements for
sending a model I'll model out there
into the wild and have it monitored and
to sort of be sort of applied safely an
automated way now maybe if you know
please let me know if you move upstream
a little bit more pre-processing gets a
check mark but only tentatively because
they see nice libraries popping up like
feature tools and teapot that automate
parts of feature engineering I think in
two years we'll know more what we can
what we do with these and what's still
left out there will get more ex insights
there I think in the near future many
people to work in there sort of the new
frontier of automation here and these
first steps think automation is very
different there because basically you
need to know your data look at it and
have a good idea what you oughta mate
makes me think of Pablo Picasso who is
quoted to say calculating machines are
useless all they give us answers and
maybe this you could take from this the
fact that you don't get you don't get
the right questions they would need for
good data science but maybe it's not
true anymore I don't know happy to hear
your opinions so finally thank you and
thank to BSM present for supporting this
study so that's it for myself
[Applause]
or the dog I think it was very
interesting I'm very condensed a lot of
information and so we can we have quite
a bit of time for questions which i
think is a good thing so again thank you
very much for the talk great
presentation
you mentioned in just one phrase the
word base oh yeah can you talk a little
bit about that and the link with these
three different methods yeah actually
you gave me sort of on the wrong foot
because I more like the frequentist guy
and not the not the Bayesian guy I mean
the the idea of patient is using a prior
four as prior information and then when
more data comes in there would be more
hyper parameters being tested you can
update the model so this the this idea
of updating this proxy model is very
Bayesian so now what's what's your prior
you could actually draw your
distributions of hyper parameters that
you find promising and some papers do
this and this would make searching more
effective if you have if you'd be like
Google that gives Excel provides model
training as a service and see lots of
different data sets you will have very
good priors for knowing what hyper
parameters to set when data looks like
this or that I think with the prior
there a predefined prior would
accelerate finding good hyper parameters
that would be the Bayesian idea if I get
it right but no guarantee because now
anyone who disagrees has to speak up
thank you for the great talk a quick
question the scores that we were seeing
in the benchmarks were those meet
average cross vowel scores or were they
actually out-of-sample scores because
I've I've seen in a few tests that one
can start kind of Oh kind of overfitting
the crossbar score even though that
sounds absurd and then the out-of-sample
scores didn't actually correlate with
the crossbar scores anymore and it's
just a cross validation so you can
actually over fit the folds there yes so
also on this evaluation so if you take
errors or whatever you other data set
you had and you have a highly flexible
model which has a nonlinear loss and
many possible configurations for
optimization so you said at one point
sometimes you only took one random seat
and sometimes it took several to
evaluate if you could basically with any
random seed and some kind of a random
process to go to the best loss you can
find many optimal solutions no so what
did you experience that there are like a
thousand 10,000 combinations of your
highly flexible model which are more or
less come to the same local minimum I
think when it comes to this being sure
and always does I think I think we can
only make very limited claims here but
are you referring just to if I
understand you correctly are you
referring to this smack situation where
you had a lucky starting point or what
are your Frenchy
yeah that's not not yeah no there's no
meters are not the same but if the loss
is still yeah probably a major
limitation here because we did not
include the study then like a evaluation
of the hyper parameter space where
however the algorithm is moved actually
it's just benchmarking that we're
focusing on so yes
it's more work to be done here yes
you're on the floor thanks for the talk
what is your take on genetic programming
as far as yes optimizing hyper
parameters because you actually
mentioned that yes this would be the
part where we left left off here I'll
just just go back to connect nicely here
where we left off here and we've seen
that random search is throwing away all
the information and then draws the net
of the next random hyper parameter to
test now you can at this point you can
improve several ways the sequential
model based optimization takes all the
points here local search I don't know if
you're familiar with local search would
just take maybe the best one and that
start searching from there which i think
is a waste I did this before in my work
and I think it's also a waste of
information and their genetic algorithms
they work very nicely the big advantages
as being very simple and very robust on
different problems they work with this
generation you say after this first
generation of nain nain nain hyper
parameters maybe only the first three
the best three ones maybe so we're here
they should survive I'll throw away the
rest and from the best three ones these
ones are recombine and then mutate them
a little bit I'll be afraid that you
might also throw away just a little bit
too much information there but maybe not
you would have to bench move probably
you have to start bench making these two
things against each other again teapot
is a good library to to explore that
works thank you yeah there other back
yeah thanks again for the talks just to
be sure I get it right so you still need
to sequence
chillie search each hyperparameters
let's see if you have n of them you fix
n minus one and optimize one right fix
one and optimize one I think with one
hyper parameter search with one time
running your machine learning model you
set each of the N parameters to one
value and then you run your machine
learning one motor whines so you have
yeah one one more in this n dimensional
space you have one more sampling point
so you don't have to sample these n
hyper parameters separately but at once
right ok ok cool thanks for a great talk
I'm a big fan of all of this and I
really like tea pot just like tea pot is
a great tool yes and I mean there's also
like Auto s : and which automates all of
that and I think it's just important to
stress that like the model parameter is
just like another parameter right it's
just another hyper parameter of the
model you choose is just another type of
parameter basically and there's also
nice cool tool called hyper Bend which I
can highly recommend
- Bend is great just more comment like
great talk yes thanks for my comment
yeah thank you could you comment maybe a
little bit on what changes are how the
approach changes if you scale up the
order of magnitude of number of
hyperparameters if there's anything
different having to or 2005 Barnabas mm
we go to this comparison here I think
the tree structure parson estimator
I think this one scares very nicely
because you don't have to model as with
the gosh process what you would do
usually you don't have to but you would
usually build one model over this n
dimensional space of hyper grammars and
the visit as many dimension that becomes
slow usually if your machine Lyon wall
is even slower and you stood well off
and this is the general rule of thumb
that whatever you do there the machine
learning model will be slower but
doesn't have to be a
point so when it comes to scaling first
parameters and also the history of hyper
parameters let you know about this one
scales very nicely and Gaussian process
I think it's scale but you have to
correct me a finger thing it scales
nicely with the number of hyper problems
but with a number the length of the
history of hyper parameters you have I
think there's like a cubic increase in
computational cost but I'm not harm
percent sure ok we just have time for
one last question so there was somebody
in this room ok hi so in your model
based optimization you use a fast ml
algorithm as your proxy for the slower
and the logarithm yes do you validate
that the like hyper parameters that you
found testing on the faster algorithm
are also like optimal for this lower
algorithm is this is this assumption
like oh yeah we could have varied the
hyper parameters we could have varied
you know the hyper parameters on these
faster proxy models three types we see
here what we did instead we use the
standard settings of the Python
libraries so we did we just wanted to
see if they out of the box can do a good
job because tuning this Gaussian process
I think it would be a bit would be a bit
harder we tried it and then we failed
and we stopped doing that and stick to
the default setting which worked better
okay so thank you very much for
interesting
[Applause]